bertrand cas ruche bonjour bonjour est
ce but si ça au caddie avec ce matin luc
de grandmaison bonjour oui bonjour alors
on vous a invité en tant que vice
président de la cacem la communauté
d'agglomération du centre de la
martinique vous êtes 14e vice président
luc de grandmaison et on va aborder tout
de suite le dossier peut-être le plus
sensible au sein de la cacem en lien
avec la ctm le transport collectif sur
le territoire de ces quatre communes
puisque la cacem on le rappelle c'est
fort de france
schoelcher saint joseph et et le
lamentin le transport collectif luc de
grandmaison à la suite des conflits
sociaux 1 et d'organisation de
délégation de service public plus
globalement et sur fond disent certains
de plus en plus nombreux d'ailleurs sur
fond de rivalités politiciennes entre
les camps pour schématiser pour aller
très vite les camps la ctm et et grands
ensembles et d'un côté et la cacem et
ppm et ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle d'un autre côté alors justement
du côté de la cacem où en est on
aujourd'hui sur ce dossier du transport
en commun sur ce conflit
oui mais beaux jours des auditrices la
difficulté qu'on en a aujourd'hui est
une réalité qui aujourd'hui la cacem a
transmis n'est plus donc responsable du
transport c'est martinique transport et
donc moratinos transports doit mettre en
place un service de transport développé
ce service de transport continue à faire
le travail qui a été fait et
malheureusement nous avons constaté qu'
il ya eu donc une délibération de
résiliation de la délégation de service
public au mois de décembre et
aujourd'hui à ce jour en tant que
administrateur de la société
mosaïque cft lui nous n'avons pas reçu
de courrier disant ça donc on a
déstabilisé la structure et un certain
nombre d'actes a été fait depuis
l'arrivée aux responsabilités de cette
majorité qui a été le premier acte a été
donc deux d'enlever les a mêlés
les médiateurs sociaux que nous avions
dans les bus qui entraînèrent est un
nombre de difficultés
et aujourd'hui on veut nous faire porter
le chapeau quand aujourd'hui martinique
tout ce qu'on n'avait pas fait les
virements de salaires et les ouvriers
roth qui enlève les chauffeurs de bus
étaient rentrés ce n'est pas du fait de
la société c'est parce qu'on n'avait pas
reçu l'argent donc gagné un certain
nombre de comportements et de
fonctionnement qui ont conduit à mettre
en difficulté le réseau urbain du centre
est aujourd'hui une réalité pour les
gens du centre donc alors on va on va
moins je ne vais pas rentrer dans
d'autres je vais rester sur la réalité
des faits alors la réalité des faits
mais à vous entendre l'avouer car ce que
l'argumentaire que vous venez de
développer on voit bien que dans l'état
d'esprit on est toujours finalement dans
cet affrontement
donc finalement kacem mosaïque d'un côté
enfin cft huées et dans le côté ctm et
martinique transport en fait est-ce que
vous ne devriez pas aujourd'hui en faire
une cause d'union sacrée et être de
véritables partenaires pour justement
organisé ce transport collectif au
service souvent des plus humbles mon
logis le mien je ne vois pas je ne vois
pas la difficulté puisque en réalité il
y a dit les gars tir de transport c'est
martin ex passeport donc nous on va
aller de ce sens
quand ils ont pris la décision de
résilier la narration vous avez du mal à
travailler ensemble mais on ne peut pas
travailler harmonieusement qui le
premier geste qui a été fait c'est de
vouloir réguler la délégation de service
public
on a dû prendre un juge pour se faire
payer la marche à blanc un juge mais
dont il faut en fait parce qu'ils disent
constater que ça fonctionne pas du tout
que c'est complètement finalement mais
finalement assez vite et ils ont payé à
l'arrivée donc ils ont ils ont bloqué le
système pour rien du tout aujourd'hui je
constate que les taxis co ne sont pas
organisés le but du tcsp c'était de
ramener les passagers aux gars de mao et
de carrière ce n'est pas fait après
trois ans et demi
la population a constaté et diacres
martinique transport identique est
vraiment il a été acculé par les
syndicats de rentrer dans les
responsabilités
eh bien ils ont mis la main au pot parce
qu'il fallait débloquer un certain
nombre de financements pour que la
société puisse vivre et les choses se
sont améliorées
vous faites le constat d'une carence
d'une certaine carence c'est une très
grosse carence et c'est une scélératesse
d'avoir si les commerçants de fort de
france du 100 du lamentin de saint
joseph et aujourd'hui ces commerces ont
été en difficulté
pour vous il ya un enjeu
politique voire politiciens dans chaque
sens que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités on entend dire ça on du
côté de mais il faut que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités comme nous sommes
restés à appeler à dire que c'est
martinique transports qui est
responsable on disait non c'est par
martinique transport non c'est pas eu
mais à la fin on a constaté que quand
ils sont venus autour de la table ils
ont mis la main au pot est débloqué
alors ils sont arrivés n'oubliez pas
avec un accident de 23 millions d'euros
à la fin de l'exercice dont qu'ils
avaient les moyens de mettre transport
digne de ce nom et je signale que il ya
un centre technique qui finit à la
pointe des grives et que personne ne
s'en occupe donc le sentier cnic et là
il faut s'en occuper il ya un certain
nombre de choses à dire que quelques
précisions récentes techniques qui
doivent être déplacés les bus d'al mahdi
ou les mettre au centre technique et ce
soutien qui nous en dira maintenant 61 2
voilà est ce cet effet et personne ne
s'en occupe martinique transpole
investit pas il le dit il ne déplace pas
le de ce lait place des almadies de
façon à ce que nous continuons à
l'aménagement de fort de france
bon alors avec les municipales qui
approche comment comment comment va-t-on
sortir sa part être une impasse ce
dossier du transport collectif
selon lui il faut que chacun fasse son
travail à son niveau d'accord et les
idées différencier les échéances
municipales et ghislaine municipales
vont arriver la population sait ce
qu'elle a à faire et je n'ai aucun doute
qu'elle fera confiance à une équipe en
place et un maître-chien au pleinement
rempli sa mission qui a relevé un défi
qui s'est mis à disposition pour servier
la ville et ça va bien se passer
bon alors voilà on a commencé que ce
dossier sensible on va pas rester toute
l'émission sur effectivement le
transport collectif sur le territoire de
la cacem en lien avec donc martinique
transports autre actualité donc pour la
casse m
c'est un second contrat de baie de fort
de france alors on dit la baie de fort
de france parce que bon voilà pour
l'appellation rapide mais c'est
plusieurs communes 1 d'ailleurs pas
toutes forcément de de la cacem qui sont
concernés et donc il ya un deuxième
contrat qui est en cours d'élaboration
il ya un atelier de concertation il ya
quelques jours le 17 juin
alors le premier contrat de baie vous un
effet un bilan une évaluation générale
et donc ça nécessite un deuxième contrat
de baie donc en lien avec le rappelle
c'est une question d'environnement aussi
un de développement économique
d'environnement
c'est la poursuite de travail entamé sur
la revalorisation écologique de la baie
de fort-de-france donc la baie de fort
de france reçoit plusieurs affluents et
qui donc aujourd'hui avec la
problématique leur d'icônes et un
problème il ya des problèmes de boue de
d'envasement 10 des coraux de qualité de
l'eau de plastique
donc il de ce travail doit continuer de
sensibilisation de la population
il ya 44 signatures effectivement sur ce
contrat de baie donc 10 viennent de
partout puis les portes portes et piloté
par la case à lacassaigne et dont
aujourd'hui il faut poursuivre ce
travail d'amélioration de la qualité de
l'eau de la cam que l'amélioration de
l'environnement écologique mais sous
marine qui permettra dans une baie
classée plus belles baies du monde de
développer des activités et de protéger
cette baie dix navires dizaine de
bateaux de toutes sortes d'activités
polluantes
oui mais si on prononce ils ont fait un
deuxième contrat b ça veut dire que le
premier a pas été complètement
satisfaisant même s'il a initié quelque
part il a déclenché l'écologie
aujourd'hui doit-être travail permanent
donc ça doit se poursuivre
donc ce contrat mai a fini premier
avancé aujourd'hui par exemple nous
avons un projet de dessalement d'eau de
mer de la sara il faut que le contraire
de baisse pour nous clairement
aujourd'hui suit les wê jet de sel dans
la baie de la sarre à six et la halle à
terme ce projet de dessalement d'eau de
mer donc il faut une instance qui veille
à l'écologie de la baie et pour conclure
luc de grandmaison donc on le rappelle
vice président de la cacem vous avez été
conseiller général avant que la mise en
place de la ctm
quel est le regard que vous portez
justement sur l'action de la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
et sur le climat qui s'y est installée
notamment le climat qui caractérise les
séances plénières ces derniers temps
non aujourd'hui ces personnes vendu du
rêve à la matinée qui nous a vomi le
pont qui al'effet l'ac milan fort de
france
moi je pense qu'ils ont ils on est issu
des pouges est un peu particulier qui
aujourd'hui après trois ans et demi on
n'a pas vu avancer le pays
aujourd'hui ils veulent faire on
pourrait par exemple pas aulas maintient
haut que moi je pense que c'est là où tu
carré ans
pepsico a qu'il faut faire faut faire
une route pour que les voitures ne
passent pas au lamentin voilà me faut
pas faire on pourrait à lagarrigue la
matière ça ne va pas régler le problème
de transport il faut faire des routes
transversales qui vont permettre de
développer la martinique et que de
fluidifier les déplacements et
aujourd'hui la collectivité montrent
bien ses limites en termes d'actions bon
il ya des actions qui sont faites ne
veut pas dire que rien ne se fait on m'a
dit ça mais on va dire je vous dis que
les orientations qui sont prises sont
qu'à particulière il faut aujourd'hui
que la martinique et les moyens au
niveau du transport ainsi toujours le
problème du transport des déplacements
pour rayer des richesses il faut que la
martinique continue à faire de
l'agriculture et on voit bien qu'avec on
arrive à la limite avec le barrage de
lamoise au point de lâcher serait-ce
donc aujourd'hui il ya une modernisation
des infrastructures à faire et je ne
pense pas que l'équipe en place et la
volonté ou la cohérence parce qu'en
réalité ils n'ont pas de responsabilité
en un pouvoir
le principe de la collectivité unique
était de délégués et personne n'a de
responsabilité personne ne signe dans la
queue dans la collectivité
on a des conseillers exécutifs qui ne
peuvent pas point de décision tout passe
par l'éclosion exécutif ne signe pas de
baby je n'ai jamais vu un papier signé
par un conseiller exécutif une décision
donc le principe de la collectivité des
délégués et quand par exemple dans le
dossier du transport louis boutrin il
est quand même bien bien avant bien
pourtant face à l'exemple sur
douteraient je n'ai pas vu pas de
décision ni l'algérie ni un mois de
janvier que ça allait démarrer dans
quinze jours ça a démarré six mois donc
je n'ai pas vu monsieur boutrin décider
quoi que ce soit on va dresser le vice
président de la cei et transport de
lévis risque d'avoir des transports mais
malheureusement je
et pas vu poindre d'initiative et avoir
un courrier signé de sa main il est vice
président il n'est pas président mais
juste réalité les conseillers exécutifs
non pas dabic c'est tout non c'est votre
votre lecture
donc voilà même le devoir maison merci
s'est décidé à terminer avec ce 7e min
au caddie à bientôt
à bientôt allez bonne journée à nos
auditeurs vous retrouver ici
[Musique]